hi in this video I would talk about how
to trace a cell secretory pathway so we
know that four cell proteins are
produced in the endoplasmic reticulum on
the ribosomes and then they are packaged
into the Golgi and from Golgi they move
to the membrane if it's a membrane-bound
protein then it would be membrane it
would be in the membrane bound condition
and if it's a secretory protein then it
would be secreted outside of the cell
now the question is how to prove that
that this is the secretory pathway of
the cell and the secretory pathway of
the cell includes ER Golgi and then to
the plasma membrane in order to do so we
can perform one experiment so we know
that vsvg
which is actually vesicular stomatitis
virus glycoprotein which is a membrane
protein so it's actually displayed on
the membrane in case of virus infected
cells so what we can do we can take
those gene sequence for vsvg and we can
tag it with the n-terminal gfp and we
can clone the whole thing in mammalian
expression vector then we can transfect
it into a mammalian cell culture after
transfecting it into the mammalian cell
culture what would happen the V is VG
containing expression vector would be
expressing into the nucleus and inside
the nucleus from this expression vector
mRNA would be produced and that mRNA
would go outside the nucleus and it
would go to the ER there the translation
would happen on the ribosomes and it
would follow the cell secretory path now
if it is following the cell secretory
path like ER then kool g then plasma
membrane then over time if we record it
in a live cell imaging that we would
find that
in several timeframe several component
of the cells are labeled so for instance
initially year would be leveled then we
would expect Galli would be labeled and
at the end plasma membrane would be
leveled so several researchers did same
kind of experiment and found that in the
0 minute you can see the ER which is
around nucleus is labeled and then at 40
minutes time after starting the
recording you can see the Golgi is
actually marked by GFP that means after
40 minutes the whole protein is actually
moving to Golgi and actually lighting up
the Golgi and if we with hundred minutes
then what would happen these whole
plasma membrane of the cell would be
actually eliminated so that also
suggests that our cell secretory pathway
is from ER to Golgi to plasma membrane
so that concludes the video on the
tracing of cell secretory pathway if you
liked my video give me the quick thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe and
please leave your comment below thank
you